i
[Music]
hello how are you greetings I came out Jaramillo
with your brief informative for today Tuesday
August 31 several fire teams
from southern Nevada are
assisting in the fire in Holder
several units from Vigo and
Clark County standards met with some
program fire crews to go
to law brought last night and control this
fire so far the plan is to
have all of them for a period of
two weeks otherwise if you show up
at mccarran airport you will notice something
different open flu vaccination clinics now
cob and that's how it is in
terminal 1 level 2 today there will be one from 8 to
10 in the morning another on Thursday from 1 to 3
in the afternoon for this week they will be
offering the facer vaccine for all
the details you can enter our
dotcom page the section  in Spanish and the
Las Vegas Raiders will have to
make important decisions. Coaches
must cut their roster from 80 to 53. This
should be confirmed by one
o'clock.  Late today the preseason ended
and now the er will face
the Baltimore Ravens on September 13
inside the stadium they choose to
start the regular season and now
we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a cloudy day today with
chances of rain for
noon reaching a maximum of 100
degrees for Wednesday we will see a
drop in temperatures with 98 degrees
on Thursday with 97 and we will be under
triple digits for the rest of the week
nice day I'm out jaramillo and this was
your brief informative of illusion in
Spanish
[Music]